what has changed in your life let's say
or your in your approach to the game
that you think helped you to succeed
this year I I can't really say because
at the start of the year I I had some
rough results some really rough results
um in for example vikin in the American
Cup and I wasn't feeling like I was
playing so amazing um but somehow things
things worked out I I did start to um
work more than I was like let's say
during covid years um this took a lot of
my
um motivation out motivation to work and
also to play and now I I feel like I've
regained it so I'm I really enjoy
working on chess again and I enjoy
playing even with the stress which is of
course always uh there's always a lot of
stress but I I still really enjoy
playing um and you know sometimes it's
like this you have waves of good or bad
um at the moment I'm going through a
period of good results and hopefully it
continues yeah